en el aprendizaje nos gustan las
preguntas los maestros nos enseñan a
cuestionarnos nos dicen cómo son las
cosas y cómo debemos responder en mi
vida el espacio siempre pido espacio
para las preguntas tanto las que me he
hecho yo como las que me han hecho los
demás de hecho cuando me invitaron a
hablar sobre educación informal una
pregunta que se me quedó atrapada en la
cabeza y que quería compartir con
vosotros por eso no me voy a quitar de
encima y es porque cada vez que detienen
al equipo lo meten en un garaje
y yo estoy seguro que a vosotros os ha
pasado por la gracia alguna vez para los
más jóvenes el equipo es un serie de los
años 80 donde un grupo de exmilitares de
lo más variopinto
ayudaban a una comunidad en peligro en
todos los capítulos eran capturados y
metidos en un granero en un almacén o en
un garaje y en todos los capítulos
utilizaban las herramientas y materiales
encontraban ese garaje para escapar pues
yo me preguntaba por qué nos sigue
metiendo en un garaje es decir también
que está lleno de cosas alucinantes pero
los malos no terminan de verlo para
ellos era un lugar donde dejar objetos
inútiles cosas abandonadas un lugar
donde dejar la basura hace poco leí que
la basura es el producto del límite de
la imaginación y esa es la diferencia
entre los malos el equipo a donde los
malos veían una masa abstracta de
objetos el equipo a veía un paraíso
lleno de posibilidades supongo que por
eso años después el taller donde trabajo
con mis compañeros tiene este aspecto de
hecho si os fijáis algunos de ellos
podrían estar perfectamente en la serie
el caso es que al terminar cada capítulo
el líder del equipo se ponía un poco
entre los dientes y decía muy pitch y me
encanta que los planes salgan bien y yo
me preguntaba pero planes qué planes os
han atrapado en una trampa os han
encerrado en un garaje o sting alimentos
a suerte de salir otra vez pero en el
fondo algo de razón sí que tenía e isaac
asimov otro tipo lleno de preguntas
decía para triunfar el mero
planteamiento es insuficiente es
necesaria la improvisación
algo tendrá razón el caso es que es una
exactamente lo que hace el equipo a
improvisar eran capaces de aunar sus
capacidades sus destrezas sus sus
valores y combinarlos para hacer frente
a las situaciones más variopintas en
definitiva eran capaces de poner en
práctica sus competencias y yo llevo
siendo educador salvaje practicante la
mitad de mi vida educador porque no
entiendo otra forma de ver la vida que
no sea a través del aprendizaje
compartido y salvaje porque sólo sé
pensar con las manos es decir
reflexionar cuando me pongo a hacer yo
me encuentro un límite una barrera lo
primero que es como desbordarla como
empujarla un poco como los bárbaros
hacían con el muro de adriano
todo esto lo aprendí en mi casa mis
padres son maestros y llegaban las
sobremesas de conversaciones sobre
alumnos claustros modelos educativos yo
como buen hijo de maestros me convertí
un alumno modelo termine en aquel
momento del cou lo que sería la
secundaria con matrícula de honor y
luego entré en la universidad y tardé 14
años en terminar la carrera
de arquitectura yo puedo reconocerle a
mis padres hoy aquí delante vosotros que
no me metí en la tuna que tampoco fui
campeón de mus
tuve la suerte de coincidir con otros
compañeros que como yo decidieron dejar
de lado el plan establecido e improvisar
y buscar otras opciones durante estos 14
años junto con mis compañeros he llevado
a cabo proyectos en los cuatro
continentes y ha sido invitado a dar
charlas y cursos en universidades de
todo el mundo como puede ser que una
universidad contrate a un tipo que solo
tiene el título de bachillerato para dar
una clase
es un fallo del sistema
y es una manera que tiene el sistema de
corregir ciertas carencias volvamos al
equipo a tú puedes ser un piloto
excepcional o mecánico maravilloso
incluso disparar mejor que el club pero
si no eres capaz de trabajar en equipo
detectar los problemas y plantear
soluciones creativas nunca saldrás de
esa garaje
en definitiva la capacidad para
improvisar pertenece al ámbito de las
competencias cómo se adquieren esas
competencias bueno en primer lugar la
educación es algo que tiene lugar a lo
largo y ancho de la vida no empieza en
la escuela ni termina cuando acabamos un
máster por decirlo de la manera como
aprendes antes inglés apuntándote a la
escuela de idiomas o echando la novia
irlandesa
como aprendes sobre mecánica yendo a un
módulo de formación profesional o
tuneando la furgoneta con tus colegas en
el fondo esta pregunta es la pregunta
trampa es decir ambos aprendizajes son
complementarios y necesarios ojo el
aprendizaje informal no es la versión
low cost del aprendizaje formal el
aprendizaje informal es el motor vital
que nos permite articular el deseo y la
curiosidad que es lo que alimenta
nuestras ganas de saber estamos
diseñados genéticamente para aprender a
lo largo de toda nuestra vida a menos
que se nos cruce en el camino un sistema
educativo perverso como por ejemplo un
sistema que nos obliga a memorizar las
respuestas en lugar de ayudarnos a
preguntarnos
podemos recuperar la ilusión después de
haber atravesado por este tipo de
situaciones
estamos acostumbrados a sistemas que
aúnan un grupo de reglas y de leyes a
través de los cuales se decide que es
válido y que no es válido y las personas
que no son capaces de adaptarse a ese
sistema acaban siendo rechazadas
podemos crear un sistema que se adapte a
las características de las personas y
que les permita desarrollarse con todo
su potencial
como bueno a lo largo de estos 14 años
que llevo de experiencia como educador
me da cuenta de que es más fácil de lo
que parece en primer lugar tenemos que
crear estados de excepción pequeños
gestos que nos saquen de la rutina y que
nos permitan transformar un espacio
anodino en un espacio mágico donde el
inesperado pueda tener lugar por ejemplo
llenar la escuela de arquitectura de
basura y promover un concurso de
construcción creativa durante un día o
llenar la plaza de los de mayo aquí en
madrid con pelotas de plástico también
puede ser que llenemos el patio del
conde-duque aquí a unos cuantos metros
de ropa de segunda mano lo sorprendente
fue cuando la gente empezó a disfrazarse
empezar a atar la ropa unos con otros
formando las grandes cuerdas con las que
jugaban a saltar a la comba durante unas
horas el patio del conde duque se
convirtió en un patio de recreo tampoco
hace falta hacer algo tan sofisticado a
veces basta con colgar un columpio en
una avenida en sao paulo
para poder sentir la ingravidez
y ojo no confundamos espacios salvajes
con espacios domesticados no confundamos
el zoo con la jungla las oficinas de
google con un taller o televisión con
internet nosotros buscamos espacios
mágicos espacios que nos emocionen nos
sorprendan nos estimulen pero también
donde podamos actuar crear activar los
espacios donde podemos trabajar valores
universales de una manera natural por
ejemplo podemos hablar de género
mientras construimos nubes con bolsas y
cartones de segunda mano para la ciudad
del cairo
podemos también hablar sobre integración
racial mientras construimos un océano de
plástico que nos señale los problemas
que hay ecológicos en las costas de
sudáfrica
si no tenemos que no es tan lejos aquí
en el sur de madrid en san cristóbal de
los ángeles un grupo de vecinos mayores
niños ancianos jóvenes adultos se juntan
y se reconocen sus capacidades mientras
recuperan un espacio abandonado y lo
transforma en un centro cultural y ojo
educativo
podemos traducir transformar estos
espacios salvajes y llevar los espacios
reglados
un estudio en 30 colegios de cataluña
decía que el patio es de los pocos sino
el único lugar diseñado exclusivamente
para el recreo y la diversión de los
niños y que además se encontraba dentro
de un centro educativo es más los niños
gastaban una media de 30 minutos al día
en ese recreo lo que hacía unas clientas
25 horas al año más que asignaturas o
materias como educación para la
ciudadanía o lengua extranjera es decir
el tiempo de recreo se había convertido
un espacio importantísimo para la
formación de los alumnos en los centros
educativos reglados este mismo estudio
se preguntaba cómo puede ser que en los
últimos 90 años estos patios apenas
hayan evolucionado podemos transformar
espacios domésticos en espacios mágicos
podemos hacerlo juntos alumnos
profesores padres madres administración
como lo haríamos que necesitamos bueno
yo aquí se quería un poco la estela del
equipo tenemos alrededor prácticamente
todo lo que necesitamos por ejemplo en
un campo de refugiados en palestina en
jordania nos juntamos para durante tres
días
reutilizar lonas y neumáticos y
construir una zona de recreo y un
espacio de sombras
en addis abeba en etiopía tuvimos una
semana para para convertir ese espacio
en una zona de juegos y un aula al aire
libre en níger niamey un grupo de
voluntarios de estos centros culturales
se juntaron para aprender a diseñar y
construir el primer patio de recreo
público del país sin ninguna experiencia
previa y transformando el espacio donde
antes quemaban los residuos en una zona
de juegos
la mera transformación de los patios
morfológica no es suficiente
el modelo pedagógico tiene que estar
presente no podemos perder una
oportunidad única para poder desarrollar
y trabajar competencias que normalmente
se quedan en los márgenes por ejemplo
las inteligencias múltiples
la responsable compartida los equipos
colaborativos y eso es lo que hemos
estado viendo estos últimos años en los
colegios en madrid tras formar el patio
desde esos valores por ejemplo hemos
hecho desde las tablas hasta caño roto
si os fijáis todos estos ejemplos que os
estoy mostrando tienen una cosa en común
son ejemplos de objetos abstractos
porque al final del día
una canasta te obliga a jugar baloncesto
y una portería te obliga a jugar al
fútbol pero un bidón de 25 mililitros
te obliga a pensar
y te viera imaginar y te obliga a
preguntarte
si a mí me preguntarán ahora donde en
cerraría el equipo a para tenerlos allí
de por vida no diría un garaje diría
antes unos laboratorios unas oficinas
unas aulas incluso una clase en harvard
el caso es que las sobremesas me dejaron
algo en la cabeza que tampoco he podido
quitar me y es que como educadores
tenemos la obligación de soñar y de
crear espacios donde cada uno tenga la
oportunidad de ser la mejor versión de
sí mismo muchas gracias